when I was a kid growing on the
Mediterranean coast of Spain I dreamed
of being an ocean Explorer diver and I
started studying marine biology and I
realized that what I was seeing
underwater was not the same thing that I
saw on Gustav's movies and I thought
that the Mediterranean was just a poor
see but then one day I jumped in a
marine reserve that had been protected
for 10 years and I realized on that very
moment everything that we lost
after 10 years doing research in
degraded environments I decided that I
didn't want to get depressed anymore so
with National Geographic we conducted
two expeditions in 2005 in 2007 to the
Northern Line Islands and there we
visited the city of islands from
inhabited to uninhabited and pristine
and that trip was like going back in
time we were able to see what the ocean
was like 50 years ago hundred years ago
500 years ago that was the best way to
understand our integrated impact on
those really gorgeous ecosystems
the Southern Line Islands belong to the
Republic of kiba's which is a pioneer
country when it comes to marine
conservation they have protected one of
their archipelagos the phoenix islands
protected area with our data and our
images we hope to establish a dialogue
with the government to inspire them to
replicate that effort on that
uninhabited archipelago so they can
provide this gift to future generations
we are a team of 12 scientists and five
media including photographers and
videographers we will leave Tahiti on a
50-meter boat and sail for a month
visiting five and explore and inhabited
Islands imagine that you want to
understand how cars work and all you
know our car wrecks in a junkyard there
is no way you're going to imagine that
this car can take you from A to B the
only way to understand what the car can
do is to go to a dealership and a study
brand new car this place we're going to
the solder Line Islands is one of the
last marine dealerships this is like the
instruction manual for how the ocean
works so this is very different from
previous research expeditions in the
sense that we are studying a machine an
ecological machine that is complete and
fully functioning
when I was a kid we had to wait months
if not years to see those movies about
those fantastic expeditions but today
with the technology the Internet we can
follow these expeditions almost real
time so we have built a really exciting
website where we will be able to report
back from the field every day and people
will be able to track the course of the
ship and also be interactive they can
ask us question about what we are doing
what we would like to know and we expect
to get back to them as as soon as
possible
one of our biggest hopes is to inspire
ocean lovers and people who don't know
their ocean lovers yet to be stewards of
our ocean planet and bring more people
and convince their policy makers to
replicate these success stories to
increase the number of protected areas
in the ocean so that at least the ocean
is as protected as the land
you